danone en 2010
laurange en 2012 les français on nous
envoie les plus voir le pool en 2017
j'aimerais bien savoir en a marre de mal
dormir elle mal manger et maintenant la
fonderie sam à chaque campagne
présidentielle son conflit social ces
élections de la fondation très gros mars
2002 le cac danone propriétaire de la
marque lui à evry des salariés
manifestent contre la fermeture
prochaine d'une biscuiterie le premier
candidat à la présidentielle à descendre
dans l'arène c'est lui lionel jospin du
parti socialiste est ce que pour la 4e
fois par mois franchement vous met au
défi vivez à 4000 francs par mois vous
allez voir le candidat communiste robert
hue s'y rendra aussi un mois plus tard
ni lui ni lionel jospin ne se qualifie
pour le second tour de la présidentielle
lusine lui fermera ses portes en 2003
février 2012 quelques semaines avant
l'élection présidentielle
rebelote après danone florange l' usine
d'acier propriété d'arcelormittal est à
l'arrêt depuis des mois françois
hollande alors candidat ps à la
présidentielle seront sur place un
conflit social marqué par cette image
celle du prétendant à l'elysée grimpant
sur le camion d'un syndicat il assure
s'il est élu le site ne fermera pas dans
une grande firme ne veut plus d'un
une unité de production ne veut pas non
plus la cd nous en ferions obligations
pour que des repreneurs vienne et
puissent donner une activité
supplémentaire autres candidats s'y
rendre philippe poutou du npa malgré les
promesses les hauts fourneaux de
florange qui paraissent en deux treize
colère des anciens salariés une stèle
symbole de la trahison de françois
hollande est même installée sur le site
et le ballet des politiques continuent
avril 2010 est le cas world poule lusine
d'électroménager est en crise des
emplois sont menacés pour les candidats
à la présidentielle c'est là bas qu'il
faut se montrer d'un côté marine le pen
candidate fn vous êtes la fierté de tous
ceux qui en france non seulement boss et
tous ceux aussi qui ont plus de boulot à
cause de cette politique économique de
l'autre emmanuel macron le candidat en
marche se rend sur place à amiens
quelques minutes seulement après son
adversaire à thème le pen elle fait elle
de l'utilisation politique puisqu'elle
va arranger des militants politiques sur
un parti encore une fois leur venue
n'auront servi à rien plus il a fermé
ses portes en 2018 cette année une autre
usine pourrait s'inviter dans le débat
présidentiel
la fonderie sam dans l'aveyron qui
sous-traité pour renault l'entreprise a
été placée en liquidation judiciaire en
novembre 2000 21 conséquence 3 133
salariés licenciés
[Musique]